have you always wanted to learn a
language have you tried language classes
or gimmicky language apps still not much
further ahead don't worry you're not
alone
why not try a new approach one that
allows you to learn directly from
interesting authentic content in your
new language real content that makes
learning enjoyable and effective that's
what you will find on Linc there's
something for everyone in the huge link
library news articles podcasts books
songs recipes whatever you're into you
can even import content into Linc always
wanted to read a book in French no
problem import it new post on that
Japanese blog imported new Facebook
message from your friend in Brazil
import it using the link reader you can
translate words and phrases in real time
move on to the next page and review what
you just learned to help it stick any
questions about what you're reading get
answers from our community access your
lessons on web or mobile lint is always
with you even offline so you can take
advantage of dead time in your day link
conveniently syncs and manages
everything so you can just concentrate
on learning meet your targets and you'll
be amazed at your progress link tracks
everything you do so you can see that
breakthrough is just a matter of time
when you're ready speak live with a
tutor or have your writing corrected on
the exchange with the right approach
you can speak another language fluently
and even better you can enjoy the
journey